con formaciones son las distintas
posiciones en tres dimensiones que puede
tener una misma molécula así que aquí
tengo el dibujo que utiliza cuñas y
líneas punteadas para el etano que es
una forma de representar a esta molécula
en tres dimensiones y acá abajo tengo
dos con formaciones de la molécula de
etano y como puedes ver ambos son
eternos pero son distintos en respecto a
su posición en tres dimensiones así que
primero vamos a hablar de cómo ir del
dibujo de cuña y línea punteada a lo que
llamamos la proyección o una proyección
de caballete aunque entonces déjenme
escribirlo una proyección de caballete y
que quizás has visto este tipo de
estructuras o estos caballetes cuando
estás en un sitio digamos que están
construyendo y bueno todo
e
y justamente estas con formaciones se
parecen a esos caballetes que usan en la
construcción así que esas son las
proyecciones de caballete si nos fijamos
por ejemplo primero en este primer en
este carbono de la izquierda es el
carbono de la izquierda está unido a
estos tres hidrógenos rojos que
justamente están representados acá
verdad esto este carbono coincide con
estos y cuáles serían cada uno de estos
hidrógenos por ejemplo este que tenemos
aquí se encuentra arriba ya la izquierda
entonces corresponde a este otro
hidrógeno de aquí este de aquí sería un
hidrógeno que está arriba a la derecha
corresponde a este que tenemos acá
mientras que este último hidrógeno pues
no le queda más que ser este de abajo
entonces si ahora nos fijamos por
ejemplo en el otro
en el otro carbono entonces pues éste
está unido a tres hidrógenos por ejemplo
este de aquí está arriba está justamente
arriba entonces corresponde a este
mientras que este carbono de aquí se
encuentra a asia
derecha verdad se encuentra hacia abajo
a la derecha mientras que éste se
encuentra hacia abajo pero a la
izquierda verdad así que esa esta sería
la conformación del etano de esta forma
verdad
ok entonces vamos a ver cómo es que
llegamos a la otra proyección de
caballete por ejemplo sabemos que este
es un enlace sigma y este puede rotar
verdad si si dejamos o vamos a pensar
que dejamos el de atrás fijó entonces
rotamos este enlace y lo que rota es
este carbono que está unido a estos tres
hidrógenos rojos verdad y que justamente
lo podemos ver en esta de acá verdad
aquí tenemos nuestro carbono
y el hidrógeno que se encontraba abajo
ahora se encuentra arriba y los dos que
se encontraban arriba ahora se
encuentran abajo entonces como puedes
darte cuenta
literalmente tenemos una gran cantidad
de con formaciones distintas verdad
digamos si hacemos una pequeña vuelta a
este enlace eso representa una
conformación distinta algo así como por
ejemplo cuando vas caminando y vas
moviendo tus brazos cada movimiento
pequeño de tu de tus brazos podría ser
una conformación distinta de ti mismo y
por supuesto digamos podemos tener
distintas conformaciones así verdad
puedes pues estar quieto puedes estar
sentado puede estar acostado ahí y bueno
algunas con formaciones son mucho más
cómodas que otras y por eso es que las
estudiamos entonces otra forma de
representar aleta no en tres dimensiones
es es un método que llamamos la
proyección de de newman
y vamos a tratar de ver si podemos
dibujar cuál es la proyección de newman
así que vamos a suponer que aquí tengo
mi ojo y este ojo está justamente viendo
hacia este enlace de carbonos muy bien
este digamos
a la vista que vamos a tener entonces
vamos a pintar una representación de
esto según la perspectiva de mi ojo ok
entonces este carbono vamos a
representarlo con un punto este carbono
va a estar representado el primer
carbono va a estar representado con un
punto y claramente este está unido a dar
sus tres hidrógenos de esta forma verdad
está unido a esos tres hidrógenos vamos
a ponerlos
nuestros tres hidrógenos y están
justamente acomodados como lo estamos
viendo desde esta perspectiva ahora bien
sería imposible ver el carbono que se
encuentra atrás así que en una
proyección de newman vamos a
representarlo como una bolita más grande
verdad como un círculo entonces si ahora
queremos pintar como veo el hidrógeno
estos hidrógenos azules podemos darnos
cuenta que este hidrógeno superior está
justo a la mitad entre estos dos
hidrógenos rojos entonces éste lo
podemos pintar déjenme poner los enlaces
como van podemos pintarlo este enlace y
que tiene a ese hidrógeno verdad y lo
mismo pasa con estos dos hidrógenos
azules si nos damos cuenta este rojo
queda en medio de los dos azules
entonces tengo estos dos enlaces que son
los enlaces de mi hidrógeno de cada uno
de estos hidrógenos azules muy bien
entonces esta es una proyección de
newman para esta conformación del
eta no ahora vamos a poner esta doble
flechita porque significa que podemos
tener otra conformación de esta misma
molécula verdad y que podemos ir de una
a la otra ya ya ya platicaremos un poco
más sobre sobre qué tan fácil es ir de
una a la otra pero pues hacemos lo mismo
verdad vamos a tomarnos este enlace y
vamos a suponer que estoy viendo ese
enlace desde esta perspectiva de tal
suerte que el carbono unido a los
hidrógenos rojos está justamente delante
del que está unido a los hidrógenos
azules entonces usamos la misma idea
tenemos nuestro nuestro primer carbono
que está unido a estos tres hidrógenos
verdad hicimos la rotación y quiere
decir que ahora este hidrógeno
estos hidrógeno se ven de esta forma
ahora bien si nosotros ponemos nuestra
nuestra bolita que significa el carbono
de atrás entonces qué es lo que podemos
observar si nosotros podemos observar
que atrás de este hidrógeno también se
encuentra el hidrógeno azul justamente
en esa perspectiva y lo mismo pasa
los dos hidrógenos de abajo verdad
entonces lo que nosotros vemos es algo
digamos de este estilo muy cerquita de
este hidrógeno se ve el otro hidrógeno
que está azul digamos en realidad
debería estar justo detrás pero sería
difícil entenderlo si no lo pinto éste
tendremos este otro hidrógeno azul
verdad que está justamente detrás del
rojo y lo mismo para el último hidrógeno
ahí lo tenemos
este último hidrógeno
así que como puedes darte cuenta está en
realidad estamos diciendo que el rojo
está eclipsando al es el azul verdad
está justo adelante y de hecho así es
como se le conoce a esta conformación es
la conformación eclipsada y déjenme
déjenme escribir esto esta es la
conformación eclipsada mientras que por
su estructura digamos que tenemos en el
lado izquierdo
esta es la conformación alternada muy
bien y estas son las dos
representaciones de newman que tenemos
para esta molécula ahora vamos a
platicar un poco sobre la estabilidad de
estas dos con formaciones y vamos a
pensar en el ángulo que se forman entre
estos hidrógenos por ejemplo de este
lado tenemos este ángulo que si nos
damos cuenta tenemos podríamos pensar
que es un círculo y lo estamos
dividiendo en seis partes iguales el
círculo tiene 360 grados si lo dividimos
entre 6 nos da 60 grados muy bien y
estoy este ángulo que hay entre los
hidrógenos se le conoce como el ángulo
torsional
torsional o también se le puede conocer
como el ángulo
yedro aunque entonces es ángulo
torsional o es ángulo de yedro en el
caso de la conformación alternada
tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados en cambio
en la conformación eclipsada el ángulo
que hay entre estos dos hidrógenos es de
0 grados y si pensamos en la estabilidad
de estas dos conformación es la más
estable es la que tiene los hidrógenos
alternados y hay varias formas de pensar
sobre esto una de ellas sería que los
electrones digamos de este de este
enlace están repeliendo a los electrones
que se encuentran en este otro enlace
verdad así que no quieren estar tan
cerca los unos a los otros así que es
mucho mejor estar más alejado es verdad
lo más alejado posible que se pueda y
hay un poquito de digamos de
hay un poquito de lo que llamamos el el
impedimento estético que está
contribuido por estos dos átomos de
hidrógeno ahora bien
estaba pensando que en realidad esto
está basado en principios de mecánica
cuántica y que realmente no tenemos
tiempo para adentrarnos en ello pero
estas son razones por la cual la
conformación eclipsada por estar tan
cerca de los hidrógenos los unos a los
otros es menos estable que la
conformación alternada verdad así que la
conformación alternada es la más estable
vamos a notar eso esto es la más estable
mientras que la eclipsada es la menos
estable
esta es la menos estable de hecho
podríamos calcular utilizando algunos
números como es que esto esto ocurre
entonces podríamos calcular la energía
potencial así que rápidamente vamos a
hacer un repaso de física sobre la
energía potencial por ejemplo si aquí
nos y aquí se encuentra el suelo
descomponerlo con una línea recta ahí
está el suelo y nosotros estamos digamos
agarrando una pelota
a mi mano
los cinco dedos ahí está mi mano y
estamos agarrando una pelota muy bien
digamos que está a 12 centímetros del
suelo
ok aquí se encuentra a una altura de 12
entonces decimos que esta pelota tiene
mucha más energía potencial que si
estuviera en reposo verdad y lo que
ocurre con la energía potencial es que
al soltar la pelota esta posición de
estar a una altura de 12 es muy
inestable
si yo suelto la pelota la pelota va a
tender a llegar a un estado donde haya
una menor energía potencial que sería
estar en el suelo verdad entonces
generalmente las cosas tienden de
tienden a ir de estados en donde hay una
gran energía potencial adonde hay una
menor energía potencial de ok entonces
si lo aplicamos a este caso si si
pensamos en los electrones que quieren
desestabilizar esta configuración de
esta molécula en realidad cuando tenemos
una configuración eclipsada la energía
potencial que hay entre digamos por esta
interacción de estos hidrógenos o de
estos electrones
4 kilos jules por mol 4 kilos
formol verdad y tenemos 4 kilos por mol
en cada una de estas interacciones a
esto es a lo que se le conoce como la
tensión torsional tensión torsional y
por supuesto esta tensión torsional es
lo que hace que la configuración
eclipsada tiende a moverse a la
configuración alternada si se encuentra
aquí pues por ejemplo el hidrógeno rojo
se entendería alejarse de estos dos
hidrógenos azules así que esta posición
es la que es más estable de hecho de
esta forma como en realidad si se puede
mover hacia esta posición pero es muy
poco probable es digamos el 99% de las
configuraciones que podamos encontrar
seguro van a ser alternadas mientras que
el 1% restante va a ser una
configuración eclipsada muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer un último ejemplo
vamos a hacer el ejemplo del propano y
para hacerlo necesitamos primero su
estructura de puntos y líneas verdad y
el propano lo podemos ver exactamente de
esta forma déjenme déjenme hacerlo más
abajo lo tenemos
vamos a poner el propano vamos
el propano aquí está este su estructura
de puntos y líneas verdad y podemos
poner por ejemplo aquí sus hidrógenos
aquí tiene un hidrógeno acá tiene otro
hidrógeno que se encuentra sobre el
mismo plano y uno que se encuentra atrás
verdad aquí se encuentra nuestro último
hidrógeno mismo caso para esta verdad
tenemos uno atrás uno por encima de la
hoja digamos aquí podemos poner su cuña
y bueno éste claramente bueno no nos va
a interesar para este para este fin de
este ejercicio ahora vamos a hacer su
proyección de newman vamos a poner aquí
nuestro ojo que va a estar viendo
justamente este enlace entre los
carbonos muy bien entonces cómo es que
pintaríamos la proyección de newman de
esta conformación vamos a poner aquí
nuestro primer carbono y si nos damos
cuenta está unido a estos tres
hidrógenos éste corresponde al hidrógeno
que está acá arriba y estos otros dos
hidrógenos son los otros que que restan
verdad así es como lo vemos desde esta
perspectiva
tenemos nuestro carbono de atrás como
esta bola de no hacerlo no tan grande
ahí está el carbono de atrás y este
estará unido a estos tres a estos dos
hidrógenos verdad primero estos dos
hidrógenos déjenme incluso ponerlos con
azul este hidrógeno y este otro
hidrógeno y si nos damos cuenta esto se
ve de forma alternada verdad ahí tenemos
nuestros dos hidrógenos de forma
alternada mientras que hacia abajo no
tenemos un hidrógeno sino en realidad
tenemos todo un grupo metilo verdad
entonces esto lo podemos ver como un ch
3 ahora bien esto todavía lo podemos
rotar verdad todavía podemos rotar esta
estructura y ponerlo de la siguiente
forma en su versión digamos eclipsada
tendríamos en vez de que tengamos uno
arriba y dos abajo tendríamos 2
arriba y 1 abajo ahí tenemos nuestros 3
hidrógenos si es que rotamos este enlace
en esta dirección verdad
dejamos fijo el de atrás y rotamos en
esta dirección ponemos nuestro carbono
de atrás y queda claro entonces que
ahora van a estar de forma eclipsada
verdad aquí vamos a tener un hidrógeno
aquí vamos a tener otro hidrógeno y acá
vamos a tener todo un ch3 verdad
entonces podríamos calcular la energía
potencial que hay en digamos por la
interacción de los electrones de estos
dos hidrógenos ya habíamos visto que es
alrededor de 4 kilos jules por mol de
verdad lo mismo pasaría para esto son
cuatro kilos jules por mol pero aquí si
nos damos cuenta tenemos muchos más
electrones interactuando verdad tenemos
no sólo los electrones de este hidrógeno
y un hidrógeno sino que además tenemos
otros dos hidrógenos y un carbono
entonces esto va a ser de alrededor de 6
kilo jules por mol lo cual nos dan 14
kilos por muy muy bien y está porque ya
está con formación por supuesto tiene
una energía potencial mucho más alta lo
cual quiere decir que en realidad la
conformación más estable que podemos
encontrar es justamente la alternada así
que esta es la forma en la que podemos
dibujar proyecciones de newman y vamos a
meternos en mucho en proyecciones de
newman mucho más complicadas en los
próximos vídeos